so for the audience for people in the
audience you might find it difficult to
remember the speaker's names because in
a true Chinese fashion that the Chinese
family names are very very popular
especially the first session let me so
let me introduce and the first dr. Lee's
the one of the three degrees in the
first first session dr. Stanley it's
important to remember post the first
name and last name for Chinese speakers
the first speaker is dr. shamli from
picking University and his title is
reward modulation of attention and
working memory in the human brain thank
you for the for the interaction
instruction from chuckling and it's my
pleasure to be here actually this is my
first time visit MIT and also posted so
we had a tool yesterday and it was
really wonderful I enjoy a lot very much
and my talk is about a revolt modulation
in our attention and the book memory in
the human brain and we have done this
work in the past about two or three
years and here we just report two
studies hopefully I can finish but
otherwise if the time is it's tight so
at least I can finish one okay so our
first riff integer introduce the
interaction between revolt and tension
and some written studies and as weeding
that reward is the most significant
motivational reinforcer and it can be in
many forms for example the food if we
are starving it's money in our daily
life of some kind of personal
achievement such as microwaves and eight
gold medals in Beijing Olympics so we
knew that but reward can increase our
motivation significantly and reward and
behavior so back to 100 years ago a
sound like proposed that in his a lot of
effect that responses to the rewarding
situation will be strengthened and
become happy to later the behavior ISM
in there operant conditioning theory
they propose that behavior can be
modified by the consequences which is
the reward and punishment however
behaviorism only allowed in there
experimental paradigm only allow the
explanation based on observable behavior
of people and animal only the stimulus
response Association matters but we do
know the internal mechanism of the
Association of reward in our psychology
science area and so we knew that select
selective attention is all helps go
directed behavior by improving the
representation of task irrelevant
stimulate and the expectation of reward
model modulates the motivational
engagement of task and affect perception
and attention I suggested suggested by
written studies but apart from the top
down attentional selection the bottom up
factors also have been shown to capture
attention by the physically stealing
items and here are some example for
example the simple orientation or carlo
singleton can capture attention very
well which is the kind of very known
papad effect and the ceilings in map the
priority ceiling the map can also show
that the bottom up attention affect our
daily life
to something about reward in this
picture if you face this kind of the
drink chef in the supermarket a Chinese
customer can be captured by the framers
that red candle herbal tea however he
may even you know the people in sitting
in front of the day that so the reward
associated item it's very important for
our behavior because for this customer
customer the association between the
radicand the pattern and the good taste
they have experienced before has been
established established repeatedly
before to investigate this kind of
effect there few studies has been done
read in regional years this one study
have been done by by Anderson in Yankees
lab and they have shown that the
previous learn that reward Association
during the video search task can capture
attention even though the this capture
capturing of attention contradict to the
current goal so in their study they have
the target in this diamond shape but the
color of high reward associated a
distractor can actually decrease the
reaction time of the radio search task
in another study by hickey in a TV lab
they have shown that if the color of the
reward the target and the distractor
swapped between choice and if the
previous file was highly rewarded the
performance of the later file could be
impaired so that means the previously
voted act trials or color can actually
impair
the forms of the observer and this is
really counterproductive and a which
lead to unsub optimal performance and
with ERG study they found that this kind
of reward capturing effect is associated
with the p 1 and n 2 pc components in
the ER he foam so this is kind of early
neuron signature of attentional
selection that means the revolts history
can really influences attention so our
study our first study was to investigate
how the learner reward association
improve the visual book memory so our
question is first the revolt Association
we knew that it leaves memory traces for
guiding attention and we also knew that
attention interact extensively based
video work memory so our question mode
can reward association improve improve
visual memory performance for the task
at hand and if we observe these kinds of
improvement which kind of apart McCann
ISM can account for it so there was two
options or two possible mechanism one
was the space-based attentional capture
effect which has been observed by other
researchers and the second would be the
feature based attentional moderation so
we knew that the this kind of classical
studies have shown shown us the very
book memory have limited capacity so
it's kind of approximately four atoms
can be installed in our working memory
and in our study we establish the reward
association which its association
between the real world and carter in the
video search training session just like
what has been done in anderson study so
in the video search training
one target carter was always associated
with high reward of monetary payment and
one color we associate with slow revolt
and the subject was not informed about
the reward color association so they
just repeatedly performed the visual
search task and to establish this kind
Association and of course in our study
the subject improved their research
performance along with the training
progress and before the training session
before and after training session we use
a paradigm of change detection to test
whether the video work memory
performance improved between after the
training session for the high reward
social cutter so the in the change
detection task the observers has to
indicate whether the orientation of the
one of the enterprise in the display has
changed their orientation and there's
prob queue for this our result have
shown that the detection sensitivity
improved and this improved was
significantly higher for the Hyderabad
associate item compared to the low
reward search item and control colors
and our analysis have shown that these
kinds of sensitive a sensitivity
improvement cannot be accounted by the
decision criterion changes so a one ask
one question we liked us was whether
these kind of improvement was due to the
attentional captured effect so we
analyzed the trials when the high reward
social Carter was distractor compared to
the trials the low reward associated
color was distractors and we found no
significant difference that means at
least four from these analyses no
captcha effect was observed when the
high watt socially
both a distractor and in our change
detection task in the post section tests
we actually include a separate one in
which a physically salient bar what a
among the search this is a detection
display and according to the physical
ceilings a theory this kind of physical
setting item will attract your attention
and so if it happens then the change
detection performance will be higher for
this case think about this physical
ceiling / however we found no
significant difference between the
physical city burn and none sitting / so
no captcha effect was observed and the
other thing we would like to do is to
validate the physical ceilings of the
seeker bar in our test so we asked
another group of subjects to perform a
visual search task so with secret bar in
the search display and we found that the
seeker bar was indeed a salient so the
reaction time for the secret about the
physical ceiling Adam was significantly
faster than the non sitting item and we
also perform another change detection
task for the seeker bar in which we vary
the ISO a which is the temperate if
interval between the sample display and
the test display and the results showed
that if SLA was short then there was a
significant physical silencing effect
for the thicker brown but if a water
longer and the same as we used in our
main experiment there was no significant
difference so this demonstrator
this is the problem the sample display
and extended isolate between the sample
and disturbed IC display to prevent the
significant sitting Z effect for our
secret power in the main experiment
however the our reward associate item
can overcome this shortage and steal a
exhibit the significant reward effect so
the next question would be if this is
not attentional capture effect then
whether this is the it can be
contributed by the kind of selection
street because the high reward and low
report item was always directly as
target including the training so we
perform another control experiment in
which the observers also perform the
video search task but they didn't
receive any monetary reward they what
they receive was just crack needs of
their response and for this control
experiment we found no significant
advantage II for the items in the color
served as target during the training so
that means the selection history cannot
account for our observed real reward
effect so the last control you
experiment we test the feature based
attentional moderation in this paradigm
so in the change detection task we
minimize the capture effect by
presenting the same color in the sample
and test display so for example here
this this is the right color for the
high reward is item and this color was
for all items items in the sample this
way and the test display in this way
there was no color difference between
the past so there was no no possibility
that the color one love the colors
capture attentions so this is result
again we found that
act detection sensitivity improvement
what larger for the item associated with
high reward and this result demonstrate
demonstrate that this is the feature to
reward a societal feature the subject
learning the training that contribute to
the improvement in the visual memory
performance we all we also did a very
nice test so the subject what asked
whether they have remember there was a
colour revolt Association doing the
training so we want to know whether the
color reward but learn it explicitly by
observers and we also asked our survey
subjects to read their confidence
confidence level after their choice and
the results showed that there was no
significant difference between the
correct knees on the correct knees
between the high reward and low reward
color however there was significant
difference than the subject rating the
confidence level and that means a few of
our subject actually explicitly learn
the reward color association and provide
a very high confidence confidence level
for their choice and to validate that
the very nice of the the reward color
Association cannot count for the revolt
effective as a burp observed for the be
working memory we do another analysis
and the results showed that there was no
significant difference between the
explicit and implicit group and if we
remove this those few subjects who learn
the rewards card association explicitly
and there was similar result obtained so
the furnace of Association doesn't
measure for the observed revolt effect
so it comes to our second study the in
this study we try to investigate if the
learned reward Association serve as a
better template for rejection so the
question we asked was the learn reward
stimulus Association firstly it starts
in memory and we knew that the memory
guided attention moderate attention in
opposite way in one way guide attention
it guide attention towards the memorized
item and it can also guide the attention
away from the memorized item so we would
like to ask can stall reward stimulus
Association be flexibly used to engage
and this game disengaged attention and
we borrow the idea from previous studies
on the template for rejection a few
studies on this topic have shown that in
if the subject was instructed to
remember one color and in the subsequent
research task they were instructed to
look for or ignore the items with the
remember the Carter some interesting
result had appeared so intuitively if
the subject was supposed to remember a
color and instruct to looking for this
car in the visual search task you will
see these kind of positive q can
increase the performance that means the
redirect time reduced however
they also found that if the subject was
instructed to ignore the memories item
and the which is negative Q and in this
case the reaction timing can also be
reduced compared to the neutral to kill
condition so that means the if the item
was taught in the working memory it can
serve as template for rejection to help
the forms of the research so we perform
a similar study investigating whether
the reward associated item of feature
can serve as a template template for
rejection better so we in this
experiment we use the similar video
search training paradigm and once the
reward card Association has been
established we test the subject in three
in two ways firstly in first group of
such a subject we ask the subject to
remember one of the two colors which is
the high reward so she ate all the low
robot associated in the following video
search task they were extracted to
ignore the remember color and our real
job show that the high reward associate
color what rejected faster that means
the high revolt associative color of
feature can serve as the template for
rejection better can compare to the
control or low reward the social card
and we did another test in which we
because the previous test we use this
symmetric display for the search display
for the video search and in second test
we destroyed these kinds of symmetry a
symmetry and we ask
the subject to remand one color and then
doing the research they is supposed to
you know this Carter and find target in
another color and finally the supposed
to report there we thought a that
remember the color and again this the
second test also show that the high
reward the social color what rejected
faster compared to the lower wall color
and nose distracted Carter they also
recording the ER key read signal from
our subjects and the ERP result have
shown that there was a significant
reward in fact for the frontal p2 which
in p2 a component in front electrode and
this is the differential activation
between the high- control color hi rod-
lovel Carter and low- controlled so
these kinds of maps show that this
differential activity happen in the
frontal regions which is related to the
company use active control and we also
found that there was significant reward
effect in the posterior piece rate
component which is peace rebbie here in
the central prada prada and the
occipital proto electron and this is the
differential activation between the
different rewarding conditions in the
and they show that this kind of
differential activation was in the
posterior area and previous previous
study have stressed that the p two three
component was related to feature based
attention or emotional security
significance all the degree of
perceptual memory matching and the p two
three component
what correlated with attentional
resources or working memory updating and
in the consolidation and also modulated
by the motivational settings which is
the case in our study and this result
have shown that the revolt effect on p
2a and ps3 be show parallel changes in
relation to the behavior event and
importantly this reward association
induce stronger but not weaker
representation during the Q period okay
it's going to be so we come to the
summary for okay fall we summary to
study together first our reward
Association a show that the it can
significantly improve video work memory
performance and the reward effect in
vivid memory can neither be counted by
space-based attentional capture now by
test strategy related to the selection
history and the learned reward
Association can facilitate perceptual
representation of high reward associate
items through feature-based attentional
moderation our observers awareness on
the reward Association differ occur
across individuals and observed the
improvement in verbal memory was not
influenced by this individual
variability and this effect mind unlike
the rare known unconscious pursuit of
value which is subliminal motivation not
embedded in the human behavior but we
need for the investigation on this issue
we also show that the reward association
facilities research performs while
active rejection of high reward
associate teacher and these kind of
reward Association can adapt Envy
facilitate task performance by
attracting modulating and inhibiting
attention so the take-home message was
reward a social item have
i bandaged it we represented represented
in vivo memory and that's be used more
readily in executive control so this the
majority of the experiment was done by
among young girl who is sitting here and
help with fittingly alpha was resistant
in my lab all right thank you oh that's
showing the Shona relationship between
working memory capacity and fluid
intelligence in oracle and sun and i was
noticing that a lot of your error bars
are very large suggestion is a lot of
individual variability in all these
kinds of measures and I wondered if you
thought about whether just variations
and the fluid intelligence that people
bring two tasks like this is explaining
some of the variability that you see
across okay actually we did analysis of
each I didn't show here and we we we did
a correlational analysis between for the
first study between the observed revolt
effect and the working memory capacity
of the subjects and we do find well
positive Cartesian significant
correlation between days however I
thought I'm not sure if this can be
extended to the flowing intelligence
issue well there was okay I think there
was the studies in past few years about
the subliminal motivation which was
quite the controversial and but I think
if these kinds of subliminal motivation
exists and it must be
it could be conveyed by the this
long-term memory stored reward a
stimulus Association and maybe this kind
of Association can play some role when
they performed the kind of task but yeah
it's not not sure yet so as I if I
understood it correctly in fact your
work memories test is after all the
trainings I so your so called attention
is associated directly only with the
training and then you is a rewarding
okay well we test the bigger work memory
capacity before and after training so
and it was the encrypt provement so yeah
you see improvement so i was wondering
this so how you I'm not how how you with
the working memory conclusion are the
working memory how is really just
associated with those early memory that
formed or in fact how that is associated
with the attention of this too okay I
think that because when we use the
change detection task that this kind of
across the classic classical paradigm
for testing via commemorate the the
interval between the sample and test
test display was about 100 a 1000 1.5
second and this period is much longer
than the shop sensory memory can last so
it's not going to be it can it cannot be
the sensory memory and so your second
question was just wondering that so
assume the maybe I misunderstood so
you're rewarding is also after training
you give the reward in that will enhance
the ok ok I'm asana during the training
and 40 trial they perform the video
search task and the target of the video
search task
what's a horizontal or vertical bar and
there was called a circle surrounding
the bar but the subject but this color
circle was task relevant to the way
research task it just it just have the
association a correlation between the
color and the search target and the
monetary reward you received after each
file